there's a couple things Taylor Swift has  definitely been Alpha widowed now an  alpha Widow basically means that there's  a guy okay have you ever heard that girl  talk about the x that she hates what  she's always talking about and goes back  to that's Taylor Swift That's I mean I  don't know if she's gone back to her  exes per se because she could just be  Alpha widowed by another bang in  Celebrity but that's the whole point so  he's gotten her after this string of  failed relationships now how long have  they been together do you know six years  so she's 32. I'm gonna give them another  two to four and then she'll leave it  around the eight year itch